der schweizer urlaubsort laax in einem
der größten skigebiete europas will der
erste co2 neutrale wintersportort in den
alpen werden zum beispiel mit strom aus
wind wasser und sonnenkraft durch gps
steuerung verbrauchen schneekanone
weniger wasser und energie
pistenraupen mit hybrid motoren schonen
die ressourcen
wir finden es sehr wichtig und die
umwelt zu kümmern denn wir möchten dass
unsere enkel hier auch skifahren können
wir müssen alles daran setzen dass der
planet und ein paradies wie dieses nicht
zerstört werden
wir müssen versuchen unser leben zu
ändern und das was wir tun und bin lag
schritte unternimmt das ist großartig
doch nicht alle sehen das so rosig
barbara moser von der internationalen
alpenschutzkommission steht auch dem
wintersport in laax kritisch gegenüber
es ist das was die leute suchen hier auf
über 11 meter hat vor allem auswirkungen
auf die landschaft mit ihrer ganzen
infrastruktur vom lärm von den
emissionen und mit dem enormen strom und
energieverbrauch des kunstschnee kommen
dann noch weitere faktoren hinzu die der
natur schaden die der biodiversität
schaden und eigentlich das zerstören was
die leute hier in den alpen suchen
nämlich naturlandschaft erholung
für nachhaltige erholung sollen in laax
hotelgebäude sorgen die mit werkstoffen
aus der region energieeffizient gebaut
worden sind
eine stadt in der man essen feiern und
schlafen kann
wie auch in rainers hotel das seinen
gästen ein ganzheitliches bewusstsein
vermitteln will
die reduzierte einrichtung soll ein
symbol gegen die wegwerfgesellschaft
sein
wir haben zum beispiel hier die stühle
die hatten gerade stille nachhaltiges
produkt auch die kann man reparieren da
bekommen wir teilen das foyer wird von
vintage möbeln dominiert und im
restaurant kommen ausschließlich
vegetarische gerichte auf den tisch
küchenchef pascal bertschinger reduziert
auch beim kochen co2 denn der strom des
hotels wird aus wasserkraft und
sonnenenergie erzeugt dennoch barbara
böser sind diese neubauten inmitten der
alpen ein dorn im auge für das geben die
leute tausende von franken aus es denkt
dass wichtigsten dass man die
natürlichen gegebenheiten respektiert
dass man die identifikation behält zudem
lebensraum den wir haben dass man das
fifa serie haben und dass auch erfahren
kann sowie interner im safiental etwa 30
kilometer von laax entfernt in dem
kleinen dorf mit rund 100 einwohnern
werden schlichte fremdenzimmer für
touristen vermietet es gibt einen
schlepplift im ort und der wird mit
solarstrom betrieben
die schaufelberger ist einer der
bewohner von tanner
die sich hier für einen sanften
tourismus engagieren weltweit lassen uns
mit solarenergie den berg hochziehen
wir sind so gut der ist uns gelingt
authentisch wir geben das was wir haben
und wie wir das ganze jahr eigentlich
hier leben in den kleinen orten kommen
die touristen reisen mit dem bus anstatt
mit dem eigenen auto
entscheidend für den co2 abdruck doch
die große masse der skifahrer kann
natürlich nicht in orten wie tanner
ausweichen
auch die großen wintersportzentren
müssen handeln dass man versucht den mit
kleinen initiativen das zu verbessern
was da ist laax kann vielleicht ein
vorbild sein und es ist auch ein beitrag
vielleicht ein kleiner eine nachhaltige
entwicklung
letztlich ist es natürlich auch eine
inszenierung weil heute ist
nachhaltigkeit auch ein lifestyle und
den wien wahlen bedienen dieses
bedürfnis der gäste bedenken
die ganz junge generation die jetzt
demonstrieren und verwaltet wie
irgendwann dann hier auch in die telekom
skifahren mit gutem gewissen lagst du
zumindest einiges damit umweltbewusste
skifahrer den wintersport nicht komplett
aufgeben müssen
[Musik]